So how would you use generate and
test to actually solve
Raven's Progressive Matrices?
We've talked about this
a little bit already, but
take it a little bit further and talk
about how you would actually implement
the problem solving
approach you've seen today.
We talked about a couple
different ways of going about it.
We talked about generating
multiple answers and
testing them against the answer options.
Or generating one answer and
testing it more intelligently against
the different options available to you.
So talk about which one you would do and
how you would actually implement it.
In doing so, make sure to think of
three by three problems as well.
With more transformations and
more figures going on,
it can be a lot more difficult
to figure out what to generate,
and the problem space can
explode very quickly.
Also make sure to think about how you're
actually going to infer the mapping
between different
figures in the problem.
How do you know which shape in
one frame maps up to a different
shape in another frame?
And then talk about how you
would use that information
to generate what you
think the answer is.